we are about to film Coenen becoming a
Wonder Woman with Galaga doh we're here
at stage 11 which fun fact this is where
they filmed er the magical medical drama
Conan is going to learn how to become
one or woman so it soon they're going to
start with a bikini wax
they're actually doing combat hand hand
combat keep boxing swordplay try to get
it's gonna be like pretty intense
physically I think I think Conan might
get beat up it's it's gonna be cool they
might learn how to ride a horse too
I think it's gonna be a good remote
they've set up we have everything ready
to go for the epic training session
mm-hmm we're in a warehouse this is
probably a famous warehouse with Warner
Brothers this is probably where either
Casablanca was filmed or The Goonies one
of those two great classics was shot
here
also the show er ER okay well there we
go Clooney was here huh Clooney was here
yeah he wrote that everywhere he went I
want to meet your trainer on camera the
whole thing and then we will begin the
process of making me wonder
he doesn't work for us the sound guy
this way gal sure help you look when I
call this it would you meet me in a
warehouse I was shocked that you said
yes I asked so many women that they hang
up before I get very far how badass the
Wonder Woman sword is that's a dog
[Music]
[Applause]
and then I'm on my knees this is a good
time to propose oh I like this part
do I back please don't run away as most
women do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
go so if you were in Tel Aviv and you
saw me walking down the street like this
and you were a single woman and no I
mean I'm walking in place I'm actually
standing still doing this in downtown
Tel Aviv are you attracted Wow yeah okay
interesting
[Music]
I have the sexual tension was
non-existent never seen a woman less
impressed of the man she's stunning
she's stunning in person and lovely and
really fun to work with and a badass
this is sad this is really sad except
they'll love me out
you